you just all of a sudden get this little
tingling and you're like my life is
ruined for ten days when they're coming
on it kind of feels like okay is this
gonna be a pimple it's extremely painful
near the end of the day I'll see that my
looks getting bigger at that point it's
like oh cool I had big looks now you
know I enjoyed that part of it finals
week any time I'm stressed out cold sore
some people get them maybe once every
two months three months or just a couple
times a year in my experience of talking
to people I just meet I can tell from
what for the most part when they're
drifting in conversation cuz I know
they're not looking at me anymore and
they're looking at the cold threats on
my face I went into a drug store I'm
like talking to her like this and she's
like okay what's wrong to live and I
like moved it and you know in my eyes
like a movies like this big dramatic
music that plays and it's like it
supposed to be like this big post dating
thing that has a voice like I am cold
sore and that's not what happened she
was like okay what do you need that was
the first like time I feel like I've
actually talked to someone and this
literally just happened this year
there was just one time in seventh grade
when I got a really bad one that's
whenever I got the name like herpes girl
they would yeah they would cheese me and
say oh look the herpes girls there was a
time that I didn't want to look at the
beer at all well that's the shame that
comes in some of this stuff that's the
believing that the t's not said not to
emotionally break yourself down about it
don't you know try to I know it's hard
not stress over it because it's not the
end of the world and there's so many
worse things that could happen that a
cold sore at the end of day is just a
little spot on your face that will go
away I'm just not gonna let it control
my life but I would just say find out
what is that triggers it I think that's
important for because it's different for
different people you have to find
something that works for you
[Music]